there's a lot of chaos and uncertainty
in financial markets right now you
literally here across the board
recession recession recession well maybe
it is coming or maybe it's not but it's
important for you to understand exactly
how to prepare for a potential recession
now if we go back and we look at the
last two recessions we know in 2008 that
ultimately there was a liquidity crisis
that means that investors looked at
their portfolio and said i'm scared what
can i sell in order to get dollars they
sold everything from stocks to bonds to
commodities real estate and anything
else that had a liquid market attached
to it they simply wanted dollars now
ultimately that liquidity crisis in 2008
played out for about six months the
government then stepped in when the
government stepped in they came with
monetary stimulus both using monetary
and fiscal policy in order to right-size
the market ultimately many assets then
rallied and ended up hitting all-time
highs in their prices if we then fast
forward to the financial recession of
2020 the pandemic was raging the
government mandated people to go sit
inside of their homes and there was
another liquidity crisis it played out
over just a matter of weeks every
investor looked in their portfolio they
were scared they wanted to sell anything
possible so they could get dollars they
sold stocks bonds commodities real
estate cryptocurrencies and anything
else that they had they just wanted the
safety of the dollar and ultimately that
liquidity crisis was reversed when the
government stepped in with monetary
stimulus using monetary and fiscal
policy to right-size the market and many
assets then rallied and hit all-time
highs if we are to head into another
recession don't be surprised if there's
another liquidity crisis where investors
look at their portfolio they're scared
they sell stocks bonds commodities real
estate and cryptocurrencies and they go
for dollars ultimately though what
people understand is that the government
is addicted to monetary stimulus they
cannot avoid stepping in they have to
use monetary and fiscal policy because
if they allow a recession to continue
then the ultimate loser is the everyday
citizen politicians are in the business
of preserving their political power and
ultimately they know if they don't step
in with monetary and fiscal policy then
their citizens will vote them out of
office and so if we go into a recession
that liquidity crisis will likely be met
very very quickly with monetary stimulus
from quantitative easing to the
manipulation of interest rates even
further down in that scenario asset
prices will then rise the way that i
personally play any sort of recessive
type activity is that i'm gonna buy and
buy and buy i've got cash that i've been
sitting on that says whether it ends up
going up or down in financial markets i
continue to just dollar cost average
over time i want to simply dollar cost
average into great assets and then hold
them for forever but if we happen to
have a recessive period where asset
prices are falling in an aggressive
manner i'll actually accelerate my
dollar cost averaging i want to buy
assets when they're at a discount now
this isn't financial advice this is how
i personally approach it but in a
recession there's a massive transfer of
wealth the scared transfer their assets
to those that have steady hands
ultimately the old saying buy when
there's blood in the streets never has
rung more true that's what i'm gonna do
if a recession comes now as we see asset
prices continue to have massive
volatility whether you're buying an
asset at somewhat of a discount or a
massive discount ultimately the
devaluation of the underlying currency
the u.s dollar is a guarantee there is
no way for the us government or the
central bank the federal reserve to stop
devaluing the dollar and so if you're
able to buy assets and hold them for
long periods of time the dollar will
devalue against them and ultimately
that's the difference between investors
and those who hold no investments it's
an education gap the investors
understand that if i hold assets and not
cash i'm guaranteed to make money
because the dollar will be devalued but
those who have no investable assets
about 45 percent of americans they still
believe that you can save your way to
financial security those are the people
who get screwed in these scenarios
inflation's at a 40-year high there's a
potential recession on the horizon what
you have to do is you have to get
educated you have to understand that
investors win and savers lose and you
have to be prepared because if asset
prices fall in any sort of recessive
period make sure that you're not the
person who's running to something like
the dollar which only is going to get
devalued at a faster rate as the
government tries to stop a recession hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time